eines der größten logistikzentren der
welt der hafen von rotterdam
1,3 millionen tonnen güter werden hier
umgeschlagen
jeden tag tausende arbeiter und
angestellte sorgen wir dafür dass alles
nach plan läuft zusammen machen wir das
wunderbar
die zahl der schiffe über 130.000 pro
jahr
damit alles reibungslos läuft müssen die
verschiedenen bereiche perfekt
harmonieren von den lotsen über die
terminal arbeiter bis hin zur
küstenwache
sie alle folgen einem straffen und
sorgfältig abgestimmten zeitplan
ein fehler und schon hätten die
dominosteine
der größte hafen europas ist zugleich
einer der innovativsten der welt
[Musik]
es ist total cool hier dabei zu sein
ein logistisches meisterwerk aber wie
genau funktioniert die riesige
drehscheibe wirklich
[Musik]
in rotterdam werden an die 14 millionen
container pro jahr umgeschlagen die
hafen region beschäftigt rund
180.000 menschen
die fläche des hafens
12.600 43 hektar anderthalb mal so groß
wie manhattan
seit seiner entstehung im vierzehnten
jahrhundert wächst der hafen immer
weiter richtung nordsee heute erstreckte
sich über eine länge von rund 40
kilometern
ganz unterschiedliche produkte werden
hier umgeschlagen
chemikalien
flüssiges massengut wie kraftstoffe oder
speiseöle
trockenes massengut wie kohle eisenerz
oder getreide und natürlich jede menge
container
2 uhr 50 am morgen heute auf dem
programm acht sich gigantische frachter
mehr als 200 lotsen bringen sie zu den
terminals martin grant ist einer von
ihnen
15 kilometer vor der küste nimmt er sein
erstes schiff in empfang
die santa clara
300 meter lang und wird mehr als 7000
containern belag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie üblich muss trend zunächst auf die
lotsen leiter springen vom an bord zu
kommen
das ist eine echte physische
herausforderung
die leiter ist höchstens neun meter lang
aber sie können sich vorstellen dass es
bei hohem wellengang und starkem wind
kein vergnügen ist darauf zu klettern
dafür muss ich topfit sein
die lotsen bringen 56.000 schiffe pro
jahr an den hafen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geschafft
hallo
guten morgen
wie geht's ihnen
zuerst die formalitäten
während des manövers übernimmt trend das
kommando an bord
die santa clara ist unterwegs
die uhr läuft bringt der lotse den
frachter nicht pünktlich zum richtigen
terminal gerät im hafen alles
durcheinander das abladen würde sich
verzögern das nächste schiff musste war
es wäre der beginn einer kettenreaktion
mit ernsten konsequenzen
den schlepper habe ich bereits
angefordert wir müssen pünktlich anlegen
und das schiff festmachen keine halbe
stunde zu früh keine halbe stunde zu
spät
das schiff soll um 730 anlegen am
terminal warten die arbeiter um den
frachter festzumachen
verspätet sich die santa clara der it
der ganze tagesplan durcheinander
ich muss meine route sehr genau planen
und mich dazu mit den kollegen auf den
anderen schiffen abstimmen
da drüben sehen sie zum beispiel ein
sehr großes schiff dem lassen wir
vorfahrt dem kommen wir lieber nicht in
die quere und
davor ist noch ein anderes schiff
dahinter der ecke
jetzt fahren wir in den hafen dabei bin
ich immer voll konzentriert
schließlich muss ich den kurs halten
die großen schiffe haben vorrang mit
dieser devise kommen die lotsen schnell
und sicher durch den hafen
das wichtigste in einem so komplexen
gefüge ein präziser getakteter zeitplan
die arbeiter und angestellten sind in
ganz unterschiedlichen firmen und
bereichen tätig trotzdem hängt alles
zusammen ist jeder auf jeden angewiesen
ohne pünktlichkeit und zuverlässigkeit
geht gar nichts
die planung für dieses komplizierte
zusammenspiel entsteht 42 kilometer
landeinwärts im herzen rotterdam hier
ist das hafen koordinationszentrum
sozusagen das gehirn des hafens
6 uhr 47 bei hafenmeister jakob buck
laufen alle fäden zusammen welche
schiffe bringen welche fracht werden
leute gebraucht und wie viele welche
probleme gibt es sonst noch
[Musik]
um solche fragen kreist die morgendliche
konferenz die einzelnen hafen bereiche
sind per video zugeschaltet die lotsen
die inspektoren und auch die hafen
patrouillen
guten morgen
[Musik]
schauen wir uns die fakten und
informationen des tages an
frank wie sieht's mit dem öl aus
hast du immer noch personalprobleme
in der schifffahrts abteilung erwarten
wir heute keine schwierigkeiten
mit gebühren und mieten und dem
containergeschäft macht der hafen einen
jährlichen umsatz von mehr als 700
millionen euro
der hafenmeister will mit seiner arbeit
vor allem die einkünfte steigern
für uns ist zeit ein besonders wichtiger
faktor
alles wird im voraus geplant ist der
plan falsch passieren fehler hält sich
ein schiff nicht an die vorgaben kann
ich regelrecht zuschauen wie ein domino
stein nach dem anderen umfeld
der
bank verantwortet auch die sicherheit im
hafen tag für tag dauern hier alle
möglichen risiken schiffbruch unfälle
beim verladen feuer explosionsgefahr
deshalb behalten was schiffe den hafen
rund um die uhr im auge
hallo hier ist jakob hey ich hoffe wegen
des eintreffenden transport seien
bei euch alles bereit
ja wir sorgen für freie fahrt
die ladung soll ja auch sicher ankommen
danke paris
später
5 nach 7 die großen frachter haben schon
fest gemacht jetzt ist die santa clara
dran
ihr santa clara wir nähern uns dem
termin
im terminal wird entschieden wo das
schiff anlegt damit alle kräne optimal
genutzt werden
die santa clara muss um 180 grad wenden
und rückwärts anlegen
und das in gerade mal 25 minuten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dafür braucht der 300 meter lange
frachter die hilfe eines schleppers
im hafen von rotterdam arbeiten 40
schiffe rund um die uhr
[Musik]
alle paul guten morgen
guten morgen ihr habt den anker
steuerbord richtig ja korrekt
nachdem die beiden größeren frachter am
frühen morgen angelegt haben muss trennt
die santa clara jetzt dazwischen
einparken
[Musik]
ist das steak 17 11 56
richtig
[Musik]
das manöver beginnt
der schlepper zieht am heck der sonntag
war
das schiff dreht sich auf der stelle
plötzlich taucht ein binnenschiff auf
und versperrt den weg
ganz langsam am eck
die wussten nicht wie sie hier
vorbeikommen sollten
hoffentlich klemm wir sie nicht ein
eine brenzlige situation
aber der lotse weicht dem störenfried
geschickt aus
[Musik]
geschafft zeit am terminal festzumachen
rotterdam hat zwei große vorteile
das hafenbecken ist besonders tief und
es gibt keine einschränkungen wegen der
gezeigten selbst die größten frachter
können hier zu jeder tages und nachtzeit
einlaufen
für die lotsen allerdings ist genau das
die herausforderung
die schiffe werden immer größer und
schwerer
das macht unsere arbeit immer
schwieriger
wir müssen alles im auge behalten was
sich rund um die schiffe abspielt
während des anliegens koordiniert trend
verschiedene tipps am kai ziehen die
arbeiter das schiff mit steps allen zu
sich heran
gleichzeitig bringt er das schiff so nah
wie möglich ans ufer
vier meter
bringt nur drei
maschinen stopp
mission erfüllt die sagt der klarer ist
verteilt und zwar pünktlich
hinten ist noch platz zwei bis
zweieinhalb meter augen können okay
danke
sehr gut wir sind fertig wieder ein
schiff angedockt
und es ist noch früh am tag
mal sehen ob ich noch gebraucht werde
wenn jahr fahre ich direkt zum nächsten
schiff wenn nein ich mich auch so
an der hafeneinfahrt ist dagegen an
pausen nicht zu denken
viertel nach acht
auf dem beobachtungsstand registrieren
die verkehrslotsen jedes einzelne schiff
im hafen bis jetzt sind es 30 der
erwarteten 80 frachter eingetroffen
[Musik]
ohne die lotsen wäre europas größter
hafen praktisch aufgeschmissen
[Musik]
der job verlangt höchste konzentration
alle drei stunden ist schichtwechsel
rené berger übernimmt die funkstation
von einem kollegen
wir müssen einen schlepper nach norden
schicken
und die rieter bekommt einen neuen
liegeplatz
im ausland oma der werker überwachte
nordsee eingang des hafens die rushhour
ist in vollem gange wie fast den ganzen
tag lang
im laufe des jahres kommen 130 tausend
schiffe in den hafen container binnen
und kreuzfahrtschiffe pro tag macht das
360 schiffe
[Musik]
das land die frecce
22 hier im ausland
wir kommen von der maas und fahren im
stau damm entlang
mein schiff 2 hier maß land sektor wenn
sie das meer erreichen passieren sie ein
kontrollpunkt
blogs für maß land sektor over
sie werden ein rausfahren das
transportschiff sehen halten sie ihren
kurs
mit seinen anweisungen sorgt der werker
dafür dass es keine zusammenstöße gibt
er muss genau vorausplanen
denn schiffe können zwar fahrt wegnehmen
aber nicht bremsen wie ein auto wenn
zwei frachter erst einmal auf
kollisionskurs sind ist es meist zu spät
die seeschiffe melden sich auf canal 3
wenn sie meinen sektor erreichen
hier sehe ich alle informationen
das timing ist ziel war die von da kommt
tiefgang
herkunft bands ladung
ab ein schiff schlepper braucht welchen
zeitplan das schiff hat
die schiffe brauchen klare ansagen
manche von ihnen sind knapp einen halben
kilometer langen mit einem tiefgang von
bis zu 24 metern
[Musik]
verbindung halten kurs halten die im
rettungsboot folgen
wir tun so als würden wir selbst auf der
brücke der schiffe stehen ein
zusammenstoß ist natürlich das
schlimmste was passieren kann
reagieren wir nicht schnell genug an das
schlimme konsequenzen haben
10 39 die hafen patrouille kontrolliert
den industriebereich
[Musik]
hier werden 80 millionen tonnen
schüttgut im jahr verladen
bei einem notfall ist die patrouille
rettungsboot und feuerwehr in einem
wir sind die augen und ohren des hafens
du weißt nie was passiert ein boot
könnte sinken oder ein feuer ausbrechen
zwei schiffe könnten zusammenstoßen es
könnte verletzte geben wir müssen immer
blitzschnell reagieren
acht patrouillenboote sind rund um die
uhr im einsatz
ein hafen muss nicht nur effizient sein
sondern auch sicher
und es ist gar nicht so einfach alles
unter kontrolle zu haben was hier vor
sich geht
[Musik]
siehst du was
ich glaub da sind auch im wasser sonst
sehe ich nichts
laut system kommt die plattform bald weg
die kriegen neue schlagzeile
scheint alles in ordnung zu sein
wir kommen wieder wenn es losgeht
sehen wir uns die schiffe am terminal an
rund 80 große seelische verlegen tag für
tag in rotterdam an sie liefern nicht
nur container sondern auch eisenerz
kohle short und gefahrgut
37 kontrolleure sind speziell dazu da
das gefahrgut zu überprüfen
[Musik]
12 20 die nächste inspektion
wenn ein schiff giftige oder leicht
entflammbare substanzen an bord hat
rücken die spezialisten an
la danse inspekteur hubert de vries ist
einer von ihnen
[Musik]
das ist eins der größten
containerschiffe der welt es hat platz
für 20.000 container
viele davon mit gefährlichen substanzen
kein wunder dass der fries bei solchen
mengen nur vier inspektionen pro tag
schafft
ich bin der ladungs inspekteur
ich möchte den diensthabenden offizier
sprechen
der fries überprüft giftige ätzende und
leicht entflammbare substanzen wie
chemikalien farben und pestizide
er will vor allem wissen ob alles
korrekt in den containern verstaut ist
stimmt etwas nicht ist nicht nur das
schiff in gefahr sondern der ganze hafen
bericht zb beim entladen ein feuer aus
können sich die flammen sehr schnell
ausbreiten
[Musik]
nehmen wir mal an zwei gefahrgut
container stehen verbotenerweise direkt
nebeneinander
bei hohem wellengang oder feuer könnten
die substanzen in kontakt geraten die
chemische reaktion könnte eine
katastrophe auslösen
de vries arbeitet seit acht jahren
rotterdam der hafen ist so etwas wie
sein zweites zuhause geworden darauf ist
er mächtig stolz
manche dinge sind nicht so leicht zu
erklären
das weiß ja auch niemand wie das
universum funktioniert aber 130
die arbeiten zehntausende und jeder von
ihnen will dass alles glatt läuft
gemeinsam machen wir das wunderbar
das universum von rotterdam
in seinen endlosen weiten gibt es sechs
container terminals für hochseeschiffe
sie zählen zu den modernsten der welt
und machen rotterdam zum größten hafen
europas
alles hier ist weitgehend automatisiert
der verlag der prozess genau so wie die
transportfahrzeuge
die betreiberfirma ece rotterdam
eröffnete schon 1993 das erste
vollautomatische türmen
die steuerung übernimmt ein
intelligentes computersysteme es
arbeitet sicher und effizienz
nur eine handvoll menschen müssen auf
dem gelände arbeiten
früher waren es hunderte
das be und entladen geht so viel
schneller
was ganz im sinne der schiffsbesatzungen
ist die den nächsten hafen pünktlich
erreichen wollen
supervisor anrede melka hat zwei
automatisierte terminals mit gebaut er
weiß worauf es dabei ankommt
die schiffe werden immer größer und
transportieren immer mehr gleichzeitig
wird die zeit für das be und entladen
immer kürzer unser ziel ist es mehr
container pro stunde zu schaffen das
gelingt uns da hat der automatisierung
das terminal hat vier zonen
zone 1 be und entladen der größte teil
davon geschieht automatisch
die einzigen beteiligten menschen
steuern den kreis
ohne zwei selbst fahrende transporter
die mit den kränen kooperieren sie
bringen die container zu den schiffen
oder nehmen welche entgegen
zone 3
ferngesteuert der trainer auf rädern
stapeln die container
und in zone 4 wird abtransportiert
zb herr lkw
das geheimnis des erfolgs sind vor allem
die automatisierten fahrzeuge sie wurden
in rotterdam erfunden und entwickeln
sich allmählich zum exportschlager
sie sparen personal und zeit
rund 100 selbst fahrende transporter
bringen die container von a nach b wie
von geisterhand
ich kann immer noch kaum glauben wie
viele container wie hier pro woche durch
schleusen
das computersystem berechnet den idealen
standort für jeden container und das in
echtzeit
wichtige faktoren sind dabei die
entfernung zum schiff die fahrstrecke
die dauer der fahrt und der
energieverbrauch
wir arbeiten mit einem punktesystem
es gibt immer einen idealen stellplatz
und natürlich auch weniger gut geeignet
das ist dem zug nach dem ort mit den
wenigsten punkten und park den container
dort
der hitze nur 41 ein weiteres schiff
beladen
unermüdlich bringen die transporter
einen container nach dem anderen zu den
grenzen aber noch hat hier ein mensch
das letzte wort
[Musik]
ich muss ganz genau im auge behalten
welche container wohin gehört
sie dürfen auf keinen fall beschädigt
werden sonst gibt es später probleme auf
dem schiff
justin funk ist einer von nur zwei
arbeitern die diesen kran steuern
er leitet informationen über jeden
einzelnen container an seinen kollegen
obenan bedienen platz weiter
[Musik]
der nächste ist er nummer drei
danke
irgendwann wird hier gar kein mensch
mehr arbeiten
aber noch ist der kranführer schneller
als jedes computersystem
[Musik]
im moment gerade ich einen frachtraum
in der mitte ist fast voll
naja ich beinahe wo die beiden kran
profis koordinieren die
containerstellplätze in atemberaubendem
tempo
der nächste ist für nummer eins
ok danke
wenn ich nicht voll konzentriert bin
kann ein unfall passieren
in rotterdam werden pro jahr 13,7
millionen standardcontainer verlagen
dabei kommt es auf jede minute an
der prozess ist einfach faszinierend
das be und entladen der container die
unglaubliche höhe das thema das ist wie
ein gigantisches puzzle
wichtig ist dass die schiffe pünktlich
auslaufen und dass dabei niemand
verletzt wird und alle am ende des tages
gesund nach hause gehen
die meisten waren stammen aus
südostasien
auch die meisten exporte gehen dorthin
[Musik]
mit dem reinen be und entladen ist es
natürlich nicht getan
unzählige firmen arbeiten an den
schiffen während sie hier liegen
das geht von inspektionen über
reparaturen
bis hin zum neuen anstrich
[Musik]
ein containerschiff braucht ganz
besonderen service und zwar am lpm
terminal
14 ein spezialistenteam erledigt einen
schwierigen und sehr gefährlichen job
einen boxenstopp während des endlagers
heute muss die schraube gecheckt und
gegebenenfalls repariert werden und zwar
unter wasser und unter zeitdruck
das schiff soll schließlich schon bald
wieder ablegen
ein wichtiges utensil dabei ein hightech
tore
[Musik]
alles okay was
alles gut erzählt den ton geht das licht
was geht das licht
das sich geht
kamera läuft
das team weiß nie wie aufwendig die
reparatur am ende sein wird
das spektrum reicht von einfachen ost
entfernung bis zu unter wasser
schweißarbeiten
[Musik]
es kommt immer darauf an vielleicht
müssen wir stahl durchtrennen das ist
manchmal schwierig wie beweist die uhr
der 24 jährige tom gotthard macht sich
bereit
[Musik]
ja als erstes kommt der anzug
für mich ist das ein ganz normaler
arbeitsoverall wie in jeder mechaniker
trägt
gott hat regt einen trocken anzug in den
luft gepumpt wird damit ist der
unterwasser praktisch schwerelos
aber zuerst ein probesprung um zu sehen
ob der anzug dicht ist
[Musik]
ich muss bis die schraube untertauchen
nur so kann ich feststellen ob da unten
alles okay ist
wir wissen nicht was da los ist also
sehe ich mal nach
sobald gott hat den helm auf hat muss es
ganz schnell gehen
[Musik]
an land ist das equipment extrem schwer
allein der helbig 13 kilogramm die
kollegen stecken noch einmal die
verbindung
zu so
wie zu
kaufen
[Musik]
der schrauben check ist normalerweise
reine routine
doch mit dem schaden den er dort unten
vorfinden wird hat gott hat nicht
gerechnet
am terminal geht es unermüdlich weiter
bei jährlich 140 millionen tonnen
container gittern landen hier zuweilen
auch unerwünschte waren
9000 kilogramm drogen waren es 2016
laut europol schätzungen wird die hälfte
des in europa zirkulierenden kokains
über rotterdam eingeschmuggelt
verdächtige container sind ein fall für
den zoll
[Musik]
pro tag sind 650 beamte im einsatz
einer davon ist fred dessen nachnamen
wie aus sicherheitsgründen nicht nennen
dürfen
[Musik]
im grunde ist er eine art hundeführer
inzwischen gibt es einfach zu viele
container um sie alle vor ort zu
untersuchen
aber der zoll hat einen weg gefunden sie
trotzdem zu checken
es werden einmal mehr container zehn
prozent anstieg allein im vorigen jahr
das ist unsere methode um die container
sehr schnell zu überprüfen
wir saugen luft ab und bringen sie zu
den hunden
fried nimmt luftproben die er später von
seinem grund checken ist ein einziges
glas genügt um den inhalt eines
kompletten container zu überprüfen
dafür muss fred den container nicht da
mal öffnen
im kampf gegen den drogenhandel spart
das eine menge zeit
[Musik]
ich gebe mein bestes um die einfuhr von
rauschgift nach europa zu verhindern
deshalb mache ich diesen job
viertel nach drei
in der zollbehörde präpariert einer von
fritz kollegen das sogenannte gläser
karussell
so kann ein hund 17 container auf einmal
abschnüffeln
die proben sind fertig ich
stelle jetzt noch eine spezielle probe
dazu um den hund zu testen
dieses lars enthält den geruch von
kokain
wir machen das damit der hund motiviert
bleibt und immer was findet
hier schreibe ich auf das nummer 16
kokain enthält der hund wird es sofort
riechen
zur gleichen zeit halten die kollegen
von der hafen patrouille die augen offen
so könnte es lücken im sicherheitssystem
geben
was genau haben die containerriesen an
bord
fest steht je größer die ladung desto
größer auch das risiko dass müssen 400
meter sein
vollbeladen
seil straff gespannt
alle sechs in gutem zustand
alles in ordnung
21 meter breit
21 breit 59 hoch
was für ein chef
brandneu
und da drüben wird getankt
das boot da hinten sollen wir ist
checken na klar
marcel jung ist zu dem zweiten
viele containerschiffe nutzen den stopp
in rotterdam zum auftanken
mobiler tanker legen direkt daneben an
und beliefern sie mit schweröl
[Musik]
wenn wir das nicht kontrollieren ist der
hafen nicht mehr sicher
ohne uns würde jeder machen was er will
bei diesem tanker liegt der letzte check
bereits drei monate zurück höchste zeit
für eine überprüfung
schweröl ist eine echte bedrohung für
die umwelt
gehen wir
hier checken alles feuerlöscher
verbindungen die ganze liste
der kapitän ist
[Musik]
an bord achten die beiden männer vor
allem auf die höhe leitungen und
brandschutzvorrichtungen
[Musik]
okay die feuerlöscher sind hier
so weit nichts zu beanstanden
[Musik]
hier ist alles okay wir wollen keine
schwierigkeiten haben trotzdem danke
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
auch in europas größtem hafen
eine gute inspektion man merkt dass wir
effektiv sind weil wir regelmäßig
kontrollieren halten sich die kapitäne
an die regeln
dank der wachsamkeit der aufpasser gibt
es auch otter dann sehr wenig
ölverschmutzung
[Musik]
jeder tag ist anders es ist ein sehr
dynamischer job
im moment ist alles ruhig aber das kann
sich schlagartig ändern
dann müssen wir dafür sorgen dass alles
in sicheren bahnen abläuft
hier in rotterdam hast du von allem
etwas
mittlerweile ist später nachmittag aber
an feierabend ist noch lange nicht zu
denken
20 nach 4
die taucher am terminal haben wir es
jetzt eilig der frachter will so schnell
wie möglich ablegen
tom gott hat untersucht mit
spezialausrüstung die schiffsschraube
und stellt fest dass da unten einiges im
argen liegt
[Musik]
erster schraube locker
zweite schraube fest wirken
dritte schraube locker
vierte schraube locker
locker
um das ausmaß des schadens zu ermitteln
taucht gott hat noch tiefer unter das
schiff je länger er unter wasser ist und
je weiter er sich vom boot entfernt
desto gefährlicher wird sein job
für alle fälle haben wir da hinten eine
zweite taucherausrüstung wenn ich ihn
nicht rausziehen kann schlüpfe ich da
rein und springt ins wasser
dann hole ich ihn so schnell wie möglich
aus
der wahl zeichnet kollege eric verbeke
alles auf video auf
[Musik]
hier zwischen 2 und 3 uhr tritt öl aus
wir sehen alles doch da kommt immer noch
höher aus
[Musik]
alle sind sichtlich bedient
der schaden ist größer als erwartet die
taucher können das leck nicht schließen
ein echtes worst case szenario
gott hat versucht noch die schrauben
fest zu ziehen aber dann steht fest das
schiff muss ins tor
das schiff verliert drei bis fünf liter
öl pro stunde das ist ernst aber
wenigstens haben wir den schaden
entdeckt und die reederei kann ihn jetzt
reparieren lassen
gott hat seine mission erfüllt
wenn auch nicht mit dem erhofften
ausgang
[Musik]
ohne ihn wäre das containerschiff eine
tickende zeitbombe
im hafen
aber auch auf offenem meer
[Musik]
schade ich bin froh dass wir das leck
gefunden haben
jetzt können wir nachsehen ob es noch
weitere schäden gibt
bei so vielen unterschiedlichen schiffen
ist es unmöglich immer alle nötigen
ersatzteile vorrätig zu haben bis jetzt
weiter stromaufwärts arbeitet der hafen
an genau diesem problem in
einer alten werft hatte namens rdm haben
die hafenbetreiber ein
innovationszentrum gegründet hier
entwickeln startups neue techniken und
prototypen für die maritime industrie
besonders erfolgreich ist der sogenannte
remlein drei blöcke feldlabor dass
ersatzteile für schiffe herstellt
[Musik]
wenn die firmen heute ersatzteile in
china oder anderswo bestellen dauert es
sechs bis zwölf monate bis zur lieferung
oft es ist nicht möglich nur ein teil zu
bestellen du brauchst zwar nur 1 musste
aber zehn ordnen dadurch entstehen hohe
lagerkosten
die lösung ein 3d metallbrücke
während es wochen oder sogar monate
dauert eine schiffsschraube zu gießen
dauert der druck nur ein paar tage
und kostengünstiger ist er auch
mit ideen wie diesen will sich rotterdam
als einer der innovativsten häfen der
welt etablieren
der bisher größte erfolg von ramla die
erste gedruckte schiffsschraube der welt
sie wiegt 400 kilogramm und hat einen
durchmesser von 13 metern
[Musik]
und schon arbeitet das team an weiteren
teilen zb aufhängungen für kräne
wir sind ein kleines team und arbeiten
sehr schnell zwischen idee und
fertigstellung lagen bei der schraube
nur sieben monate vor ein paar jahren
wäre das noch undenkbar gewesen
damals hatten wir weder die werkzeuge
noch die digitalen möglichkeiten
es ist total cool hier dabei gewesen zu
sein
rotterdam entwickelt sich zu einem
smarten hafen
beim zoll sind fred und ein zehn monate
alter spüren tmax auf dem weg zum gläser
karussell
max wird proben aus 17 containern
kontrollieren und zwar gleichzeitig der
bislang größte drogenfund in rotterdam
waren
4600 kilogramm kokain in einem einzigen
container
[Musik]
max ist einer von 30 spürenden beim zoll
er ist auch den geruch von kokain
spezialisiert
das ist die meisten geschmuggelte druck
[Musik]
max
max ist noch in der ausbildung fred
trainiert wie ihn wie jeden anderen und
auch
mit einem stöckchen
der hund muss das richtige glas
identifizieren wenn er es findet bekommt
er eine belohnung dafür tut er alles und
ich spiele hinterher mit ihm
er ist glücklich dass er etwas für sein
herrchen tun konnte
[Musik]
am 16
max hat die kontrolle probe gefunden in
weniger als fünf sekunden
gut gemacht bravo kurzerhand
um ganz sicher zu gehen muss ein zweiter
und dran die container können erst
freigegeben werden wenn er zum gleichen
ergebnis kommt
[Musik]
und so ist es
schlüssel probe bestanden
wir haben ein negatives ergebnis keine
der wunde hat etwas in den containern
gefunden
wir können die waren also freigeben und
die untersuchung beenden
für den hafen heißt dass an den
terminals kann die arbeit ohne
verzögerung weiter gehen
[Musik]
nach und nach legen die schiffe ab und
machen platz für die nächste lieferung
[Musik]
ein teil der waren wird von
binnenschiffen weitertransportiert
[Musik]
einige container reisen mit der bahn
weiter
andere landen auf einem lastwagen
in der verladestation ist auch am frühen
abend noch einiges los
18 37
in der zentrale überwacht eine handvoll
mitarbeiter das terminal und managt das
be und entladen
die trucker brauchen nur eine einfache
chipkarte
das system erkennt sofort welcher
container abtransportiert werden sollen
normalerweise dauert das beladen nur ein
paar minuten
hallo kommt
super ich bin bereit
die schienen kräne am terminal werden
per joystick gesteuert so werden die
laster beladen
die roboter haben die container schon
vorsortiert
nur der letzte schritt das
herunterlassen auf den laster geschieht
noch per hand
[Musik]
eingerastet ja
na dann gute fahrt danke das erste
vollautomatische terminal der welt hat
supervisor anträge melka viel arbeit
gekostet jetzt ist er vor allem stolz
am anfang war das hier ein einziges
großes durcheinander
ich dachte das schaffen wir aber mit
harter arbeit haben wir die
produktivität gesteigert das ergebnis
ist fantastisch
ich bin sehr stolz dass wir das hier in
rotterdam geschafft haben
rotterdam hat die anderen häfen hinter
sich gelassen und ist heute europas tor
zur welt
[Musik]
der hafen ist in jeder kategorie die
nummer eins container feste ladung und
flüssige ladung
die vielen tausend menschen die hier
arbeiten versuchen den hafen von
rotterdam jeden tag ein bisschen besser
zu machen
innovativ
zuverlässig
und mit leidenschaft bei der sache
[Musik]